getting ready for a day of work Ronnie
Dunn Pacoima earns a living as a cook
animate in a private home in Central
Delhi she has to ensure she leaves her
own home on time every morning her
commute involves a 10-minute walk
navigating Delhi's fierce traffic in
order to catch a bus she only just makes
it today it's not an easy ride the bus
is absolutely packed there's no air
conditioning
despite the blistering summer heat
Ronnie is lucky today she actually gets
a seat she spends the equivalent of
about fifteen to seventeen US dollars a
month on the tickets it's a hefty sum
for her but Ronnie says the worst part
of a daily 45-minute commute is facing
rampant harassment and bullying
you face so much sexual harassment men
deliberately press up against you
they're shameless often you don't get a
seat male passengers occupied the seats
reserved for women they refuse to budge
you have to fight to get it then there
are pickpockets there are just so many
hassles but I have no choice I have to
get to work but they may actually be a
choice for women like Ronny in future
the Delhi government says it plans to
make all publicly funded busses as well
as the Metro free for women Delhi's
metro network is often hailed as a
game-changer in the city's bid to expand
public transport it's a far cry from the
bumpy buses on the city streets there's
even a dedicated compartment for women
it's widely considered the safest mode
of transport but tickets aren't cheap
following fare hikes last year
authorities say women now make up just
30% of Metro commuters that could change
if the free rides become a reality the
Delhi government says its proposal to
make public transport free for women
would go a long way towards improving
their safety in the city the argument is
that accessible modes of transport will
encourage more women to join the
workforce and also allow them access to
public spaces dominated by men but on
the streets of Delhi opinions are
sharply divided over the move I think
it's a good move for women right now so
many working women have to pay so much
on just commuting you should install
CCTV cameras and stuff like that it will
it will increase a woman's safety not
just making transport free of cost I
think it's unfair for men because
already the rates are so high they will
have to pay more because since the woman
women are traveling free for women like
Ronnie however free public transport
could be empowering the 40 year old has
never ridden on the Metro but she says
she would consider a joyride if it's
free of course I'd love to try it
it would certainly beat the jostling on
the bus Ronnie is convinced that free
rides will definitely get more women
like her out of the home adding to an
enhanced sense of safety in numbers